from Lady Gaga's show-stopping  performance to Rihanna slang her  Coachella look celebs are going all out  in the desert  [Music]  Gaga surprises fans with new music  during her epic headlining show in Indio  California Saturday mother monster  turned heads in a black police hat and  leather trench coat singing hits from  her Born This Way album halfway through  her set she debuted a new single The  Cure then there's Rihanna rocking out to  Coachella Tunes sporting a look that  only she can pull off RiRi wore  bedazzled Sunny's a sparkly silver body  sued under a Gucci tank top and short  shorts she captioned the pig quote I  can't go home yet cuz enough people  ain't seen my outfit  you